[Music]
Why are you enduring this hardship,
this squid
?
Coolia Jiro,
making a list and reconciling with the goods, fifth place
How about the para-
lady?
I think I've gone too far with the post office,
but you're living together, so please
protect a little bit of privacy.
When I say beauty
treatment
, calm down
I'm upset just because I can't see you, what should I do?  The right thing to do is to show your
demeanor It's better to pretend that
you're caught I'm the one who firmly supports the mental aspect of being in a silly position I don't realize that I'm the one who's being made to dance in the palm of my hand
It
's my English that makes me want people to live
like that.